Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
I've been trying to
listen to my conscience,
but I can't tell the
difference between fear,
willful blindness or genuine conscience.
Well,
the first thing I would say about that
is it is quite clear that you are in fact
trying to listen to your
conscience because that's
probably the first thing that
you discover.
So that's a really good question.
Okay.
Fear,
Oh,
here's the test and you don't
want to do this stupidly.
If you think that you should do something
and you think that the reason you
might not be doing it is
because you're afraid,
then you should do it.
Okay?
So that way you can find out if it's fear,
you know?
I think your question is,
well,
how do I know my conscience isn't
just masquerading as fear saying,
well,
you shouldn't do that,
but it's rationalizing the real issue,
which is you're afraid of doing that.
Yeah.
See,
here's a reason that you
want to tell the truth.
And I parked,
I kind of figured this out when I was
looking deeply into the Pinocchio Story.
You know when Pinocchio as
Pinocchio strives to become real,
he,
he has a conscience to guide him,
but it's jimminy cricket,
this insect.
But Jimmy hasn't really
got very good conscience.
He's a bit dogmatic to begin with,
dogmatic and didn't experienced.
And so it's,
it's not like the conscience
is an unerring guide.
It's like a partner in discovery.
And as you move forward in your life
and you consult your conscience and you
listen to it,
then it gets smarter and so to you.
But there's a code of there.
And this is why I've suggested part
of the reason why I've suggested so
frequently in my lectures and in
my book that people try not to lie.
You see,
there are many systems,
you have many systems within,
let's say,
that guide you and one of those is
your capacity for rational thought.
And then you have a variety of emotional
systems and motivational systems and
internal dramas and intuitions and bodily
sensations like lots and lots of and
sensors,
lots of systems that are guiding you.
And many of them operate,
you might say,
unconsciously,
autonomously,
instinctively,
implicitly,
all of that.
Now you PR nonetheless,
you program them like
you feed them content,
let's say just like you
feed your body nourishment,
you feed them content and a lot of the
content that you feed them pertains
directly to your voluntary thoughts
and speech and your actions.
And then if you
pathologize those by lying.
So if you say things that you know not
to be true or you don't say things that
you know to be true when you need to,
which is more common.
And if you act in ways that you consider
that back act in ways you considered
reprehensible,
then you pathologize all of those
autonomous systems that guide you.
It's like you're programming them badly.
You're building an AI system
inside yourself really in,
in,
in some sense that is what you're doing.
That has very bad,
it's very bad training data.
And so the output it produces will be,
we'll won't guide you properly.
And so you don't want to
pathologize your guidance systems.
It's a really bad idea.
So that's why you have to not lie.
And maybe that's also why you
have to say what you have to say.
And you have to say it clearly as well.
And you have to learn how to do that.
So that's one of the ways of getting
your conscience straightened out.
And then you have to have a
dialogue with your conscience.
And you might ask,
it's like,
okay,
well what should I do?
Or what should,
should I do this or should I not do this?
So let's say you're thinking,
should I not do this?
In the case of a temptation,
maybe you have a chance to
develop a new relationship.
You know,
and you're,
you're excited about it and apprehensive
about it and afraid of it and you don't
know how to sort out all those feelings.
And the first thing is you really
have to want to sort them out.
That's why you have to orient yourself
to something that's a genuine up.
You know that the star above the horizon,
you have to really want things to be
straight and you have to have thought that
through.
And you have to know what it means
for things not to be straight.
And really what it means is that you're
headed for hell in one way or another.
And if you understand that it's enough,
maybe it's enough to scare you straight.
You really got to think that through.
Then you've got to think about how much
better it would be if you aimed up and,
and that really has to kind
of permeate your whole being.
And so then you're oriented that way.
You're oriented up and you're deciding
that it's okay to try to tell the truth
and then you can start to rely on
this dialogue with your conscience.
But both of you have to learn and you're
going to make mistakes along the way.
You know that that's okay.
You can say,
well,
I'm going to try this without
being certain that it's right.
You can even say,
I'm going to say this without
being certain that it's correct.
Like if you're arguing with your
wife or your husband or your,
or your sister,
your father,
and you have an idea about
what might be going on,
you can say,
look,
here's my idea about what's going on.
Um,
who knows what that idea
might be contaminated with,
like maybe I'm putting it forward just
because I'm too proud or arrogant or
angry or fearful or whatever.
That's possible.
Let's see if we can figure that out.
But you can offer it tentatively
and both have add it.
That's what you do if it's a hypothesis,
right?
You both have at it and see if
it's an idea that's worthy of,
of keeping you do that with
your conscience and then
you weren't move forward.
There's this,
there's a technique and behavioral
psychology called psychotherapy called
collaborative empiricism.
So let's say that we,
you and I have been sitting down and
we decided that you're going to try
something new this week,
like maybe your agoraphobic and you're
having a hard time in a parking lot.
And so getting out of the car
and going to the grocery store.
So maybe we say,
well in to drive to the grocery store
and you just get to walk halfway to the
halfway from your car to the door and
that's good enough for like do that every
second day for a week and then
come back and let's talk about it.
So that's collaborative empiricism,
you're running a little experiment,
you think,
well your conscience is
guiding you towards something.
You take a tentative step in that
direction and then you check and see,
well,
you know,
did what I wanted to have
happen or occur as an outcome.
That's the crucial question.
And that's the crucial
question for behavioral truth,
right?
That's the pragmatic perspective.
Did what I want to have happen happen
as a consequence of my framework of
interpretation and my action.
If the answer is yes,
then I have not invalidated it.
Right?
That's,
that's the pragmatic
philosophy in a nutshell.
And it's,
it's very,
very smart.
So you have a dialogue
with your conscience that
never ends and hopefully it
gets wiser and you get wiser.
And
that's the dialogue that young talked
about between the conscious and the
unconscious,
between your,
your fantasy life,
say the life that sort of underneath
you as a conscious being like the life
that's part of your biological platform,
the biological platform that somehow
miraculously gives rise to your
consciousness.
If a dialogue with that,
we're always in dialogue.
We're always in dialogue,
right,
with everything.
So
pursue that.